and no one's going to gay bars anymore
you know it's like you just I mean yeah
they started killing people
no no no I was that one I went with them
get killed well I was the murderer
yeah yeah this is for Jesus
on the way in I thought I told you this
the bouncer on the Boiler Room it was no
no Boiler Room is uh I know where they
all are but uh oh yeah I almost said no
both rooms down yeah
no no it's it's in um Hell's Kitchen
Hell's Kitchen what is the name of this
history therapy uh hard Hardware I love
these names I'm gonna figure it out
the squad that was a place in uh San
Francisco one yeah holy yeah that's a
real one yeah it's awesome yeah not even
a gay bar that's how gay San Francisco
is
five